au salon de l'agriculture 2010 9
dégustation de produits du terroir
français
découvertes gustatives visite
incontournable des animaux et petit
bisou pour certains je compte devenir
agriculteur dans quelques mois
et ça me semblait intéressant une c'est
une opportunité pour moi de venir de
voir un peu autre chose
et parmi tous les stands du salon
bientôt du vin 100% yvelinois en 2017 la
winery parisienne a planté ses premiers
pieds de vigne à d'avron elle veut
réinventer la filière viticole en
ile-de-france privé pour nous était de
reproduire des vins dans la plus grande
l'ancien plus grandes régions viticoles
de france les villes de france pour
produire des grands vins dans la région
sur la plaine de verfeil la première
cuvée est annoncée pour 2020 côté
assiette la ferme d alu et propose des
légumes anciens et nouveaux
sur les étalages topinambours radis noir
ou route à bagua j'ai une cinquantaine
d'hectares
en fruits et légumes que je revends sur
les marchés en ile-de-france 40 rouge de
bruxelles rouge novembre vraiment des
légumes qui sortent de l'ordinaire
le département des yvelines est le
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france
il participe au salon pour la deuxième
fois avec les hauts-de-seine ils sont
complémentaires parce que l'agriculture
c'est une production et une consommation
et si les yvelines sont un département
producteur ce que les hauts-de-seine ne
sont pas les hauts-de-seine comme les
yvelines d'ailleurs sont des
départements consommateurs et en
particulier consommateurs dans nos
cantines scolaires de nos collèges les
yvelines favorisent les produits locaux
et intègre les produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique au concours
général agricole
y a eu la médaille d'argent sur un
yaourt à l'abricot destinés à la
restauration collective pour les enfants
des écoles du département
notre gamme
on va envoyer vous faites 30 à 40000
euros par mois qui sont dédiés
quand une eau plus tôt le territoire des
yvelines est composé de 90 mille
hectares d'espacés agricoles
avec près de 1000 exploitations
l'agriculture c'est un marqueur fort des
yvelines aider à l'installation et au
renouvellement des générations
il faut installer des jeunes
agriculteurs des jeunes agricultrices et
donc on y travaille en les aidant
financièrement on les aide aussi à se
transformer au niveau écologique
énergétique
alexandra dublanche également adjointe
au maire de sartrouville n'est pas la
seule à vouloir mettre en avant les
agricultrices dans les stands du salon
clémentine errigo miss france agricole
élu le 15 décembre et présente ses plus
les vieux barbu au fin fond de la
montagne qu'il ya il ya vraiment un
nouveau souffle dans le monde agricole
avec la jeunesse et les femmes dans
l'agriculture
concilier développement urbain et
développement économique agricole un
enjeu que les visiteurs ont apprécié ces
moments
monde son nom
on fait voir beaucoup des choses qui à
paris justement il n'y a pas de vingt
cinq années et à chaque fois eu
l'occasion d'accompagner mon petit fils
j'ai eu pas mal de nouveautés
c'est tout ce côté bio et goûter les
produits éventuellement vous pouvez
encore faire un tour le salon de
l'agriculture se termine ce dimanche 3
mars